ahora vamos a utilizar una tabla de pk a
recuerda de química general que pk
es igual a menos el logaritmo base de 10
de k
y entre más bajo sea el valor de pk
más fuerte es el ácido los valores pk
son utilizados muchísimo en química
orgánica por lo cual es muy importante
que nos familiaricemos con ellos por
ejemplo si nuestro ácido es hcl el pk de
este protón es aproximadamente menos 7
entonces si por ejemplo tenemos una base
por acá cualquier base y la base se
lleva a este protón entonces pues estos
electrones se quedan con el cloro
digamos que esos son estos electrones
entonces cl - es la base conjugada del
ácido hcl y entre más chico sea el valor
pk
más fuerte es el ácido entonces de todos
los ácidos de esta tabla hcl tiene el
valor pk
más chico y por lo tanto es el ácido más
fuerte de toda la tabla y como sabemos
de química general entre más fuerte sea
un ácido más débil es la base conjugada
aunque para que un ácido sea fuerte
su base conjugada debe de ser débil para
poder resistir la re protón acción si es
muy fácil perder un protón debería de
ser realmente difícil recuperarlo
ok porque si no no sería un ácido fuerte
ok entonces hcl tiene el valor pk
más chico de toda la tabla por lo tanto
es el ácido más fuerte y su base
conjugada él anión cloruro tiene que ser
la base más débil aunque el cloruro es
la base más débil de todas las bases
conjugadas que están en la columna de la
derecha
tabla bueno ahora vamos con este ácido y
en este ácido
este es el protón ácido así es que si
tenemos una base que llega y se lleva a
este protón de aquí y entonces estos
electrones de aquí se quedan con el
oxígeno estos electrones se quedan con
el oxígeno lo que obtenemos como base
conjugada es una molécula de acetona ok
y esta tabla lo que nos está diciendo es
que el pk
de este protón ha sido de aquí es
aproximadamente menos 3 ahora en muchas
tablas revistó distintos valores de t
caac para este mismo protón de hecho he
visto hasta -7 en alguna otra tabla
así es que utiliza el valor de pk a que
te den en tu curso para este protón
ácido y bueno siguiendo con otro ejemplo
por aquí tenemos hidronew y si llega una
base genérica
y se lleva a uno de estos protones el
valor pk para cualquiera de estos
protones es menos 2 aproximadamente y
bueno estos electrones del enlace se
quedan en el oxígeno así es que podemos
dibujarlos con morado por acá estos
electrones se quedan aquí formando una
molécula de agua como nuestra base con
jugada de líder o neo ok entonces
podemos empezar a comparar algunos
ácidos por ejemplo aquí el líder on yo
podemos observar que tiene un valor de
pk
más grande que hcl y eso lo que
significa es que el idóneo es un ácido
más débil que el ácido hcl o también lo
podemos decir al revés
hcl tiene un valor de pk más bajo que el
libro neo y entonces hcl es un ácido más
fuerte que hidro neo bueno vamos a ver
más
ejemplos de ácidos con sus bases con
jugadas y sus valores de acá y por aquí
tenemos ácido acético sabemos que este
es el protón ácido que tiene un pk
de aproximadamente 5 por qué bueno si
llegara una base y se llevará este
protón entonces estos electrones de aquí
se quedarían con el oxígeno los estamos
dibujando por acá y le darían a este
oxígeno una carga negativa formando el
año nace tato por craig el anillo nace
tacto es la base conjugada del ácido
acético y en el siguiente compuesto
tenemos aquí
estos dos protones ácidos y realmente no
importa cuál de los dos protones se
lleva la base pero estos protones tienen
un valor de pk
de aproximadamente 9 y cuando la base
llega y se lleva a este protón estos
electrones de aquí se quedan en el
carbono
estos electrones de aquí y déjame
circular este carbono y obtiene una
carga formal menos 1 vamos con el
siguiente compuesto tenemos por aquí
renault y el protón ácido del fenol es
este de aquí así es que si llega a una
base y se lleva a este protón los
electrones de aquí se quedan en el
oxígeno vamos a dibujarlos por aquí y el
oxígeno obtiene una carga formal
negativa -1 que hay entonces este
compuesto de aquí es la base conjugada
del fenol y el valor pk de este protón
ha sido de aquí es aproximadamente 10
vamos por más ejemplos el compuesto que
tenemos aquí es una molécula de agua y
cuál es el valor de pk para este protón
de aquí pues es aproximadamente 15.7 la
base conjugada del agua es el hidróxido
y ahora tenemos etanol y su protón ácido
es este de aquí que tiene un valor de pk
a de aproximadamente 16 y estos
electrones se quedan en el oxígeno vamos
a dibujarlos por aquí dándole al oxígeno
una carga formal negativa -1 y formando
una unión eta óxido ahora que tanto más
ácido es el fenol en comparación con el
etanol y recuerda entre más chico sea el
valor pk
más fuerte es el ácido y tenemos un
valor pk de 10 para este protón mientras
que por acá tenemos un valor de
aproximadamente 16 para este protón de
aquí entonces que tanto más ácido es
este compuesto en comparación con este
otro y aquí lo que tenemos que hacer es
recordar la definición de peka peka
es igual a menos el logaritmo base de 10
de k
entonces
entero de diferencia entre estos valores
pk
es un orden de magnitud completo es como
multiplicar por 10 entonces como aquí
hay 6 unidades de diferencia este
compuesto es 10 a las 6 veces más fuerte
que este otro compuesto porque pecaa es
menos logaritmo base 10 de que a ok
entonces el fenol es un ácido un millón
de veces más fuerte que el ácido etanol
y esto es algo que tenemos que tomar en
cuenta cuando estamos viendo una tabla
de pk y es muchísimo más fácil trabajar
con valores pk
y por eso se utilizan tanto en química
orgánica pero bueno vamos con otro
alcohol
este es el protón ácido que tiene
aproximadamente un valor de pk
de 17 esta es su base conjugada este
protón nacido de este otro alcohol tiene
aproximadamente un valor de pk
de 18 y esta es su base con jugadas como
puedes observar aquí tenemos tres
alcoholes con distintos valores de pk
y más adelante vamos a explicar por qué
estos alcoholes pueden tener estos
distintos valores de pecar pero bueno
vamos a ver más compuestos este protón
tiene un valor de pk de aproximadamente
19 así es que si llega a una base y se
lleva a este protón estos electrones de
aquí se van a quedar en este carbono
aunque vamos a dibujarlos por aquí estos
electrones se quedan en este carbono que
entonces obtiene una carga formal
negativa -1 bueno ahora vamos con el
siguiente tenemos por aquí acetileno sid
es protón amos el acetileno este protón
tiene aproximadamente un valor de pk
de 25 los electrones de este enlace se
quedan en el carbono que los podemos
buscar por aquí y entonces el carbono
ahora tiene una carga formal negativa
y esta es la base con jugada y ahora
para el amoniaco si una base llega y se
lleva uno de estos protones estos
protones tienen un valor de pk ad36 y
estos electrones de aquí se quedarían en
el nitrógeno podríamos dibujarlos por
aquí y entonces el nitrógeno tiene una
carga formal negativa -1 y bueno en
realidad este es otro de esos compuestos
en los que hay muchísimas tablas con
muchísimos valores de pk a distintos que
hay pero en esta tabla tenemos que es 36
he visto 33 he visto 38 entonces al
igual que el inicio de este vídeo
utiliza el valor de k
que estén utilizando en tu curso y ya
casi vamos a terminar ya nada más nos
faltan dos compuestos entonces empezamos
por aquí cuál es el valor pk de este
protón pues es aproximadamente 44 y los
electrones de este enlace se quedan en
el carbono
haciendo que el carbono tenga una carga
formal negativa -1 y este es la base con
jugada de este ácido y finalmente el
etano que es el ácido más débil de todos
los ácidos que hemos visto en esta tabla
el valor de pk de este protón es
aproximadamente 50 y los electrones de
este enlace se quedan en el carbono el
carbono tiene una carga formal negativa
-1 ahora si el etano es el ácido más
débil de todos los de la tabla entonces
su base conjugada debe de ser la más
fuerte de toda la tabla
así es que también puedes utilizar las
tablas de valores pk
para identificar cuáles son las bases
más fuertes si por ejemplo aquí
tuviéramos un ácido déjamelo dibujo
tenemos un hidrógeno entonces estos
electrones de aquí en morado llegarían y
se llevarían este protón volviendo a
forma
aretha no está funcionando como una base
que se re protón y vuelve a formar eta
no
entonces entre más fuerte sea una base
más débil es el ácido conjugado y las
tablas de valores pk son muy importantes
para pensar en que tan fuertes son los
ácidos pero también para pensar en qué
tan fuertes son las bases